on the deal on the table is a five
percent pay rise for this financial year
as well as a one-off payment of up to
three thousand seven hundred and eighty
nine pounds it's been rejected by
members of the Royal College of Nursing
and unite but approved by other unions
including Unison the GMB and those
representing midwives and
physiotherapists so the unions will now
vote on whether to accept the deal at a
meeting of the NHS staff Council this
afternoon
the vote will work like an electoral
college with each Union's votes being
weighted by their membership Unison with
the biggest membership will have the
biggest weight in and small Elite unions
like cop the Royal College of Podiatry
have less weight in the British dietetic
Association and the Federation of
clinical scientists are yet to announce
how their members have voted but even
without them it looks like the NHS
payoffer will be accepted Sarah
Carpenter is a spokesperson for unite
whose members have rejected the deal she
says the offer still equates to a pay
cut